you'll see questions like this and
really this is trying to get ad
do you understand those log walls right
you remember how you add it to the round
with months but I divide good morning
but can you use them when it's really
like you don't just get told which ones
you need to use it's a little bit like
the difference between you know um how
many of you've got something from Ikea
before anyone really sir okay alright so
you know in an Ikea like box right I'm
you get the instructions out and every
single piece that you need is there good
morning and they're all labeled and you
know like the steps are all there and
say okay this is what I have to do right
it's all mapped out for you all the
steps are pretty clear unless you've
hurt right even without any words
assuming you know put anything backwards
I've done that before
ah but but that's very different
actually making like a cabinet right
account is okay I have all of this
material and like I have some tools but
I don't even know which ones I'm
supposed to use you can put something
together but clearly the second thing is
a lot harder than the first thing right
this is in the second category you've
got all the tools we've got the numbers
at your disposal
but you're not given much direction as
to how you should use them to get this
result okay so I'm just going to do the
first half of it and then we're gonna
jump into polynomials which is our real
topic for today okay so these are you
all doing blocks yeah yeah okay who
knows what these numbers are
excuse me they're going to be something
with lots a lots of decimal garbage on
the end very imprecise numbers but even
though I don't know what they exactly
are I can still work with them and I can
combine them in predictable ways okay so
let me give you an example you see how
this number PR is going to be bigger
than this number over here
this is like how long do I take to grow
to this versus how long ready to grow to
this okay so therefore it's that's the
reason it's something I could do is have
a big number and take away a small
number do you think that is reasonable
be number two take away small number
okay so I could write something like
this log 108
take away blog Zeke's okay now at the
moment I'm just kind of feeling my way
through the question I don't
have an idea of how to solve this right
but I don't I'm gonna have to combine
these two in some kind of way okay so
let's just see if this is going to yield
us anything useful
we know log [ __ ] when you subtract
logs what happens to those numbers in
there on the inside what do I do with
them I divide very good subtraction
turns into division right
so my next line would be this now I'm
not the greatest that my 6 times tables
right so 108 108 half of that is 54 but
I know how many six is going 54 I don't
think it's gonna 54 I think it's no I I
think 9 6 is going to 54 anyhow you
calculator can check that there's twice
as many here right so there won't be 9 6
in there there will be 18 of them ok so
I have this are you okay with that is
that reasonable now that's not bad
that's like this that's true it's not
either be honest is that I I want log 3
for instance that looks like it's an
easier time to kid so see how I went
from here to here it gave me a small all
right I could do this again couldn't I
I could take say log 18 I can get that
in terms of these two which I know I
could subtract log 6 again do you see
that if I subtract I'm gonna do another
division you can probably do this one in
your head
right what's the difference you're gonna
be when you do 18 divided by 6 it's just
gonna be 3 right that's actually answer
that I'm after right so this is me just
trying to work out okay
is this some way I can combine many
pieces in order to get to this and I can
okay so now how do i express this in the
language of the question right on these
things here are really just that's it
this is called B and this is called a
right I did B takeaway that gave me this
right that wasn't quite where my answer
was I mean you need to go
further I needed to take that answer and
I needed to subtract a another time
therefore okay what I can do is in
summary what I've done is I started with
B and then I subtracted a twice that's
to rate see that that let's just verify
that this actually works right that's
more 108 takeaway to log seeks to look
six okay maybe see if I'm going to get
the same result as what I just saw maybe
to you write to log six I can do another
log Lord here right which one do I have
in my just frozen now I can i it's the
powell or isn't that true you can hop up
the top and become 6 squared which is 36
so Lord 108 take away log 36 this looks
familiar
this is the subtraction which turns into
division which is the log 3 that I was
after okay so now we might be take away
2 this is my answer to the first part
okay haven't got my answer for the
second part yeah and then we can dig
into it after we do polynomials but this
is the process this is the process I
went through ok it wasn't a straight
line there but that's because I didn't
know what the straight line was so I
just kind of had to view my way through
as I made some progress I was like oh
look I've got something meaningful now
let's translate that in terms of the
question ok so the reason why I like I
could have just gone here I could have
said hey everyone let's do but you take
away to a but there's no obvious reason
why you would do that at first unless
you know exactly what you're doing most
of us are not in that category
we're in this category up here were you
kind of like I am Not sure I'm just
going to try these I'm just gonna
as they say quickly for things against
the wall and see what sticks right and
some of the things work they made some
progress
ok so this is the way I would approach
questions like this you've got your
building blocks just play with them a
little bit and see how they can fit
together ok